- New Zealand has no native
land mammals other than bats.
For around 85 million years,
these islands were so remote
that the rest of the world's mammals
just never made it here.
All the parts of the ecosystem
that mammals would fill
instead went to birds,
or lizards, or insects.
A lot of those birds are flightless,
because there was nothing
they had to fly away from.
And even the bats spend a
lot of time on the ground.
Then in the 13th century, Māori arrived
bringing with them one now-extinct
species of dog, and Polynesian rats.
That wasn't great for the local species,
and then in the 18th century,
Europeans arrived and
brought... a lot.
Rats, stoats, ferrets,
weasels, possums,
all predators which the local creatures
had not evolved to defend against.
If New Zealand wants to
keep its unique ecosystem
and wants the local species to recover,
at least the species that
aren't already extinct,
then the blunt fact is that
either the local species
are going to survive,
or the predators are.
The only places in the
world that have managed
to completely eradicate invasive species
are very small islands a few
square kilometers across,
or fenced-off reserves that are
regularly patrolled and studied.
And most of those are in
and around New Zealand!
But clearing something
the size of a country,
and a rural country at that,
that's not just a challenge,
that's a moonshot.
So today I met with people
from Predator Free Wellington,
because they're some of the folks
who are making a start on it.
- So this is one of
our trusty trap boxes.
They get pretty hammered out here,
with all the elements.
- There's no one in there right now? Okay.
- Hope not.
[both laughing]
No, it's still set. It's still baited.
- Okay.
- And then we've got a
bait station there too.
It's basically toxin.
So this is basically a
very secure plastic box,
it's locked closed so
that pets and children,
that sort of thing, can't get
access to the bait inside.
And then in here, we've
got a toxic wax block.
- Oh, you're just touching that.
- Yup.
[both laughing]
- Well, people or even cats and dogs
would have to eat a
huge quantity of this
for it to have any effects, whereas a rat
only needs really five grams
or so for a lethal dose.
- Oh, wow.
- So it makes it a really effective tool.
There's also an antidote.
- And that is presumably
delicious to rats.
- Yeah, they tend to love it.
I don't know what the flavor is in there,
it's a cereal-based bait, basically.
- Right.
- And then this other one
here is kind of interesting.
- We'll wait for the plane.
[plane engine roaring]
Right next to the airport.
- This is called Detex,
so it's a non-toxic type of
bait and rats love to eat it,
but the reason we use it is because
it actually glows under
UV light, bright green.
And so they'll eat this
and then their droppings
or their urine or even
their insides will glow.
And so for us and our barrier
system, it means that
if we detect a rat along here
somewhere,
or we catch one in a trap,
we can work out where
it's come from, basically.
- Right. So that peninsula
is free of rats.
- Yep. Just about.
- That section isn't.
- Yup.
- And the buffer is, right now,
the airport and this bridge here.
- Yeah. So the airport provides a
really nice natural buffer area
because rats don't
particularly like to be out
in the open where it's super exposed.
And so we don't see much evidence
of them crossing that
big concrete expanse.
- So the plan is: start at the
edge of the Miramar Peninsula,
eradicate the predators there
and then establish a buffer zone,
and then keep pushing
that buffer zone back
and back and back and back
until eventually there
are no predators left
in the whole of Wellington.
- We've got about 5,800
traps in our network
and then about 6,800 bait stations
of varying types.
- The trap to me just looks
like a box with a hole in it.
- Exactly.
- And, if the rat can get in,
how does the rat not get out?
- It's basically an entrance on one side
and the mesh at the other
side they can see through,
so it looks like a clear run for them.
Which we've found
makes them more likely to
go inside and investigate.
And then we've got some
lure inside as well.
So there's a paste that
just smells really good
and so they'll go in for a nosey.
I can whip this open, there we go.
- Oh, okay. Yeah.
- So it's a pretty grunty trap.
- Yeah. In my head, up until this moment,
I was like, oh, it's a trap.
The rat goes in, the rat gets trapped,
you release the rat...
No, you don't.
- Yeah, no.
- No. That...
- No. This is definitely a lethal trap.
- Yeah.
And it's humane certified to
the New Zealand standards.
So we basically want traps
that the animal's not
going to suffer more
than it needs to.
It's going to be pretty
instant, pretty powerful.
I can give you a demo of
setting it off if you'd like.
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, it's kind of really
brutal calculus, isn't it?
Either the rat dies or the
unique species here dies.
- Unfortunately. Yeah.
I mean, it's never nice
to have to kill animals
and rats, I've got a
lot of respect for them,
they're great creatures
in their own right,
but unfortunately they just can't coexist
with our native species.
So, I can give this a demo.
- On that note. Yeah, let's...
- So I'm just going to use my gloves
'cos they're nice and soft,
and lob them in
and hopefully that will set it off.
Two, one. [trap clanks]
There we go.
- Okay. Yeah.
- So it's pretty punchy.
- That's going to be messy.
- Yeah. - Yeah.
How often do you have to
clean one of these out?
- Not very much these days, thankfully.
- Yeah.
- Along here it's still
reasonably rare but we do catch
probably about three rats each
time we service this barrier system.
On the peninsula,
we're catching a lot less
rats now, which is nice.
Yeah. Especially in this hot weather.
- You really do have to be so careful.
- Oh, yeah.
- How many people do you
have working on this?
- So we've got a full-time
field staff of about 25,
and then there's a few of us
in the office as well,
doing the data crunching
and that sort of thing.
- That's way more than I thought.
- And then on top of that, we've
got a huge volunteer force.
So they make up about 10%
of the efforts on Miramar Peninsula.
- Right. And it's government
funded, presumably?
- Yeah, a lot of it is.
So it's a big collaboration, this one.
So, what we can see here, we've had a rat,
come along and chewed this
monitoring card of ours.
- So we call these chew cards.
They're a really effective
monitoring tool.
It's basically just a
piece of corflute plastic
and then we mash peanut
butter into the gaps.
- But it works a treat.
So it's been here, within
the last week we know,
because we've serviced
this quite recently.
- You can't poison the peanut butter then?
- Unfortunately not.
We considered the avenue,
but I don't think the...
- Of course,
because that's something
that other creatures...
- Other creatures could get to.
A dog could have a nibble.
And it's also the combining
of toxin with food
is one of those things that...
- Oh. - ...I don't think you're
technically allowed to do.
So, we've got to be very
careful to keep it all safe
and legal and all of that.
- No, the trap has not been set off now.
- The trap's not been set.
So it's had a nibble,
it's getting interested,
but it hasn't gone in yet.
- Yet. [both laughing]
- The trouble is, as long as there's
a breeding pair of rats
anywhere outside that
buffer zone, there's a threat.
Alberta in Canada is the only place
outside of the poles
where there are no rats,
and that's because rats
never got established there.
A combination of harsh geography
on all sides
and a vicious, almost obsessive
government-backed control program
kept rats out, and
still does to this day.
That's what Wellington will
always have to deal with,
unless they just keep pushing.
The reserve here, this is where
the rats have been eliminated
rather than suppressed, right?
- Yeah, exactly.
So it took us about six months
of really intense efforts,
but we've now eliminated all
of the rats out of this area.
- So how do you know?
- We've got a lot of
monitoring that goes into it,
trail cameras, a big one.
They're just about the
golden standard we can get
for monitoring rats.
You can see there's one
just tucked down in here.
- Oh, spot the city boy.
[both laughing]
Oh, okay. Yep.
- So they're camouflaged to blend in
as best they can, so that
the rats don't notice them
and it's pointed at a motor lure.
It's basically got a
syringe of mayonnaise inside
with a little motor.
- Sure, okay.
- And once a day, it
basically pushes out 1ml of
mayonnaise from this syringe.
Without us having to come
here every single day,
it's keeping a fresh food source
and a fresh lure for these rats.
- And anything that comes to eat it...
- Gets caught on camera.
- Right.
- Yeah. It's a really
effective way of basically
telling us if there's
any rats left in an area.
And rats seem to love egg mayonnaise,
so it works pretty well.
- And are there any left?
- Not in here.
It's been a huge effort, but now
we can safely say it's rat free.
- Is it working?
Well, it seems to. The statistics say
that animal life is
recovering on the peninsula.
The key thing is, this isn't
limited to just Wellington,
across the whole of New Zealand
there are groups doing the same.
There's a government plan
called Predator Free 2050,
but it is optimistic.
The plan that even admits
that to pull this off on a national scale
they'll need some new scientific discovery
to make this easier.
And "new scientific discoveries"
and "ecosystem management"
are words that historically
haven't gone well together.
Do you think it's going to work?
Do you think that they'll get
New Zealand clear by 2050?
- I think they will, yeah.
I think just looking at
the progress we've made
in the last couple of years
already, particularly here,
we've learnt so much
in the last 12 months
that if you extrapolate that out,
I think we've definitely
got a good shot of it.
I think we'll crack it.
- Can it be done?
Maybe. With enough money,
time and human effort.
And from my limited time here
I'd say that protection
of the land and ecosystem,
the Māori word roughly
translated is 'kaitiakitanga',
it seems to be part of
New Zealand's national identity,
in a way I don't think I've seen
in any other country I've been to.
Towns, regions, sure. But never a country.
If anyone can pull this off,
it's going to be New Zealand.